This is a psychological aspect
of achieving good pronunciation.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today I
want to talk about natural pronunciation.
Now, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So I wanna follow up on the
fascinating discussion that I had
with Stephen Krashen the other day.
And that was a live stream.
And you may have watched it.
It's available uh, here for you to,
uh, look at if you, uh, weren't able
to participate in the live stream.
It is also going to be available as a
lesson with subtitles, with the, uh, the
transcript in our English library at LingQ
where we have a number of videos from Dr.
Krashen that you can use if you're working
on improving your English and if you
want to become more familiar with Dr.
Krashen's ideas.
Now, in the conversation with Dr.
Krashen he had a, he has wonderful
stories to tell, but one of his stories
was that, uh, he was in a French class
or he heard about someone who was
in a French class and who was always
criticized for his pronunciation.
His pronunciation wasn't very natural.
It wasn't, I mean, we don't have to be
totally native, but it was still very
much far away from French pronunciation.
He was in a way hiding behind
his English pronunciation.
And then for whatever reason,
he decided that he was going to
impersonate, imitate a French person.
So he arrived one day in front of the
class and he put on a beret because
people think French people all wear...
french men, all wear berets, which they
don't, and he pretended to be a Frenchman.
And he was, you know, we can imitate
French people speaking English, like
very often, some people can imitate
the French accent, the English...
but when they go to speak French,
they're still using their English accent.
So he decided that he was going to
pretend to be a Frenchman with his beret,
with whatever other disguise he had on.
And he spoke French and he spoke with a
very good accent with good pronunciation.
And the teacher said, where has
that pronunciation been hiding?
And of course he was in the mood for that.
And so I think we can achieve if not
native-like pronunciation, which is more
difficult to achieve, but we can achieve
comfortable pronunciation pronunciation
that the native speaker enjoys listening
to, even with an accent that feels
natural, that is not strained, but is
free of the inhibitions that too often
people feel when they're hanging back in
the safety of sort of pronouncing French
...  in other words, staying with the less
risky sort of pronunciation of not making
an effort to imitate, not to take that,
that jump into the, what might be cold
water of trying to actually sound like
whatever language it is we're learning.
I mentioned to Dr.
Krashen that I have referred to
this as cultural weightlessness and
that this is a psychological aspect
of achieving good pronunciation.
There are many other things that
we can do to improve pronunciation.
Uh, listening is certainly one,
listening to things that engage us
emotionally is going to help us.
But also at some point you have to
recognize that you have to sort of lift
yourself up, this cultural weightlessness.
You're not a part of
your native culture now.
You in fact are gonna try to sort
of immerse yourself, throw yourself
into the water, into the culture of
the language that you're learning.
You're gonna pretend to be one of them.
And if you do that, and, and I
think that's, as I said, also to Dr.
Krashen why very often actors, I
remember once hearing Jody Foster
speak French, she has phenomenal
pronunciation in her French.
She makes mistakes on her.
gender So it's not to say that her
French is perfect, but if we are
concerned about pronunciation, if we
think of an actor or an actress that
has to, they're no longer, she's no
longer Jody Foster, she is whatever
person she's playing in the movie.
And so actors are used to the
idea of projecting them themselves
into the role of someone else.
And when we speak a language, not
only do we have to learn the words and
the phrases and so forth and improve
our comprehension, which I always
stress, but if we want to improve our
pronunciation, if we want to achieve
natural, comfortable pronunciation,
comfortable for you using it, comfortable
for the person listening to it - it
needn't be perfect - I think that requires
that willingness to play act to, to
sort of pretend you're someone else.
And once you've done that a few
times, that then becomes the natural
pronunciation for you because you have
now moved as a speaker, I use French,
but it could be any language, you've
moved from being sort of a foreigner
attempting to speak the language to
this new role where you see yourself
as a member of that cultural group.
And I think if we can learn to do
that, and it's certainly what I try
to do when I learn a language, we
then develop what I would call natural
pronunciation, which is not the same
as native pronunciation, because
realistically it's very difficult to
achieve, uh, uh, a level of pronunciation
that is where you'll be mistaken for a
native, by and large not gonna happen.
However, you can achieve a
level of pronunciation that is
very pleasant, very natural.
So that's my recommendation when it
comes to pronunciation and I'll leave
you with a couple of, uh, videos that
I've done in the past on pronunciation.
You may also wanna visit the, uh, Krashen
interview whether, uh, at the YouTube
channel here or in our library at LingQ.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.